foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
oh oh my gosh
hey am I in focus
am I in Focus cause
I'm gonna make sure we don't Focus for
this one today yeah welcome everyone oh
my gosh this is the monthly hundred
dollar joke contest as we say here in
the hot breath of ours what's goody what
is goody my friends
all the hot breathers out there
the hot Brethren and cistern
new and
young alike
we are already deep in here oh my gosh
we have Mary and Cole and Joan and Aaron
and say it Jerry and Daniel
Bob Jack yo we deep in here Shawty we we
deepen these streets we we sit in about
a pretty 30 right now in this live
stream fam
not bad for not promoting it
yes I've been on the road this weekend
so I literally like just got back and
made the link and everything so
I appreciate all y'all for hanging out
this is our monthly hundred dollar joke
contest
officially welcome I welcome you
officially now
this is the first of its kind you're in
for something great here and you gotta
hang out because we were doing a live
voting on who wins and then we're
bringing the winner on the show live
for an interview q a you can ask the
winner questions as well so it's going
to be a goody timing here
and we roll in deep today oh my gosh
Jody
what's goody fam what's good Dino coach
Tosh Evelyn oh my gosh
oh my gosh Sandy
oh we we deepen these streets today oh
my gosh I love it Linda
good morning Linda
Linda today
we are actually doing our
um Whatchamacallit our 100 joke contest
every single month we do a contest where
people
submit
a 90-second set based on a theme that we
post every month and then the top three
finalists or it's a little different
today but typically the top three
finalists then do this live stream and
we play each of their sets you watch you
vote you decide this is a hot
breathocracy
ooh but you get to decide who is the
winner and they get not only a hundred
dollars the winner but also an interview
on the world famous hot breath party
unbelievable
so
how it's gonna work today though
this is our final one of the year I know
the holiday season is Among Us upon us
and I don't want anyone to feel the
stress or obligation
to submit a set this month feel free to
write feel free to continue to write and
create and such but um we're gonna take
a step back on the contest this month
and then hit the ground running in
January just to give you all a little
you know balance is important as well
and you know this is a big big big big
time of year so I just wanted what this
contest to it started as a fun way
to hold ourselves accountable to write
new material every month
so um we're going to keep that fun
Spirit today with our first ever
first ever
first
ever oh and Emmanuel's in here what's
goody fam good to see you Emmanuel
okay good people are tuning in like wait
what is this
yes this is our monthly contest we're
about to watch the finalist sets we
usually pick three
my my wife and I always watch all the
submissions we love it it's it's good
quality family time
and we could not Whittle down a top
three this time and each each month
people keep getting better and better
because they keep submitting and they
keep getting better at writing and
performing
and we just could not this month we
watched all the submissions
we whittled it down to four and we were
like
let like we were trying to decide and
then we're like all right let's just
sleep on it when we wake up we'll know
and then on our morning walk
we brought it up again and
we're like we got to go with the top
four we just we just can't decide so you
the hot breath verse will decide who
wins today so
yes
oh Evelyn in here
what do you go yo yo yo
Evelyn Thatcher we have two Evelyn's in
here hello
hello
oh and Linda sorry for the confusion she
said so I cannot enter
um no well not this month the
participants are graduates of our comedy
writing master class so anyone that
joins our comedy writing Master Class
can participate in this
in perpetuity so
um
if you're interested I can share a link
in the comments how you can join the
writing master class but it's a fun way
to you know pay Comics to write new
Jokes which is what we're all about here
in the hot breadth of verse just Comics
helping Comics so
that is what we're doing today
is you're going to get to participate
actively in making a Comics dream come
true of winning the hot breath hundred
dollar joke contest
and Bobby Sutton's here said Joyce and I
are in DC performed with Sandy last
night
and are going to play with Joan today
after the contest oh my gosh
oh my gosh why am I about to cry
I love that oh
the hot breath versus alchia
so exciting I'm glad because I saw y'all
post that the Charlotte show
um was canceled to perform in Baltimore
so I was hoping that meant you were
gonna get to go connect with Sandy and
bonus Joan because I know Joan is in DC
but when I went up and did the show with
Sandy I made a
made a route through DC to connect with
Joan as well so it's definitely y'all
are gonna have a blast out there oh my
gosh
oh y'all
yo
all right so let's get into it shall we
let's get into it here
as Jody said like a young young Angus
Young from AC DC oh thank you
thank you so much
I'll take that as a compliment
oh
oh Sandra Dawson here as well oh that's
great yeah we got to do Sandy's show
together
oh I'll breath versus working it's out
here as we say we out here
Mike said she missed me in Richmond ah
next time
next time Mike yeah I just had a comic
he just bought my um I saw my comedy
special on my website and uh
then I get people's when I when they buy
it I get their email and I'll reach out
and thank them and then we started
talking and uh it's an aspiring comic
in um
uh Richmond who said he wants to get on
stage by the end of the year so
maybe after watching my comedy special
for those of you who haven't seen it
wink wink
it's a great holiday gift good clean
family fun right there grandkids the
grandparents bring them all
and
I saw Mary said share the master class
link so here
it is
and maybe
um
I should give you a direct link to it
because we have like a whole online
school
but I should give you the link that'll
take you directly to the class because
we have classes and workshops in there
just depending on what you're looking
for
cool beans
all right oh Bobby so we discussed
putting together a hot breath hot
flasher store was Sandy hilarious
all right well let's get into it my
friends what do y'all think
thank you
oh gosh share the link to my comedy
special too well Lord
yes and it's by donation you know you
can pay what you like for it I I
self-produced it
released it on my 10-year comedy
anniversary
and um
super proud of it
so if you enjoy all the fun free stuff
going on here at hot bread that's
another good way to um
keep the lights on so my wife doesn't
make me go back to Enterprise Rent-A-Car
all right
so here we go
we getting into it here fam
we getting into it
here we go all right this is the first
of its kind here this is the first
of its kind
a four-way
final
so here's how it's going to work we're
gonna do
um we'll do Jack Allen first then we'll
do Sandy Bernstein then we'll do Bob
Kirk and then we'll do Joan fuchsman so
that will be the order basically how
it's going to work here my friends
we're going to watch each set
watch each set and then at the end I'm
gonna post a poll in the live chat on
YouTube and then you will pick one you
will vote for one of these people to win
this month's contest a hundred dollars
and an interview on hot breath podcast
so
let's get into it my friends and as you
watch this just keep in mind the theme
this month was honest
so keep in mind when you're watching
these how they use the word the theme of
honest
how do they use it to personalize their
material how on theme is the set and
also just how funny how many laughs are
they getting in these sets and um
we're gonna have fun here this is so
exciting so without further Ado my
friends
dab
let me see
my gosh I did I did a a holiday party in
Knoxville this weekend
and um
those are always fun and they were there
were kids there and there was a kid
sitting on the couch in the front who
was laughing and that tried to get him
to dab and he was like nah he was like
Najee
he was 10.
okay I guess yeah
we'll get them though we'll bring we'll
bring these kids back around
yeah the set went great though the set
went awesome
oh come on
all right
so let's get into it here my friends
keep in mind keep notes as you're
watching these as well
the theme is honest how creatively do
they use the word theme how personal is
the material and how funny is the set
keep these in mind
as we're watching each of these sets
and there's only one thing left to do
and that is oh no I don't know if I have
that sound effect queued up one second
this is the whole reason we're here
y'all it's gonna be worth it I promise
the whole reason we're here is for this
sound effect
where is it because we gotta play it
but what is
here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
first up
we have the one and only Jack Allen
here we go
hold on
hold on all right here we go
where's the thing all right Jack Allen
here we go
I like my honest School teachers look
Class A large portion of you are going
to be unsuccessful but just remember
when life gets tough you can always take
an overdose
you know I was so jealous of my friends
with separated parents like two sets of
gifts at Christmas
if my dad would have cheated on mum like
I could be sat here right now with an
Xbox and the PlayStation
please please Dad please hit on the
secretary ah I won a Nintendo
you know my parents were always taking
me to the doctors he put a stethoscope
to my chest and say oh I'm sorry Mr Mrs
Allen I'm afraid your son is
a disappointment you know buying
Christmas gifts is about honesty brother
10 pound sister 10 pounds Grandad oh now
you were worth 15 pounds but the chemo
divided your mass by three so five
pounds for you spend it wisely perhaps
on some carbs you know I hate greetings
cards a selection of soppiness mother my
love for you which is the highest of
mountains ugh I want a card it's just
look Mom you're right you know
you did a job
um thanks not drinking during pregnancy
perhaps I'll even get one for Granddad
next time check your prostate you lazy
bastard R.I.P I
all right give it up for Jack
Allen
give it up for Jack Allen yeah
[Music]
rip got like my accent R.I.P y'all like
that
or RP
well done there Jack Island that is just
the first as well but We Came Out
Swinging on that one We Came Out
Swinging
no diggity no doubt
shake it all about
oh Sandy said love the ending Ed
said great job Jack Mary giving a lot of
laugh emojis
Jones so great Jack I love the greeting
cards bit oh
Evelyn Thatcher
hitting some hahas Jerry Kroll superset
Mike Marr very expressive Lynn Biden
funny Jack Evelyn Medcalf great job Jack
thanks for not drinking during the
pregnancy
do you know said where can we buy Jack's
greeting cards oh my gosh
I've definitely thought about that
before I I feel like
um knowing so many funny comedy writers
we could definitely create a lot of
funny greeting cards and I've seen like
some at like local stores and stuff
like some locally made ones
uh I thought about that before that is a
funny idea I think I think we could
definitely kill it on
Bob said good one Jack R.I.P not
drinking during pregnancy
nice yeah that was a big hitter there I
know we came out the gate swinging on
that we came out the gate swinging on
that and y'all
but we got three more
oh and Jack said Thank you guys I
appreciate it
let's set up a realistic greeting card
store that's a good idea there Jack
that is a good idea there
oh yeah people like the greeting cards
yeah I don't know
I don't know the logistics or anything
like that but I definitely I mean
I think it's definitely untapped
you know what I mean
Mary said they've sold well
Evelyn Thatcher please cheat so I can
get more gifts LOL
yeah that was a I really like that one
that was a good one
I want to Nintendo
I'm not butch I don't mean to butcher
your accent there Jack all right
oh
but
that's just the first one my friends we
have three more here okay these are all
quick 90 second sets so you gotta pay
attention keep track of what you like
about each person's sets because at the
end we're gonna vote and bring this
person on live for you to answer for you
to ask questions and we're gonna post it
as a podcast as well so we're just
getting all fancy in here y'all we just
so fancy
all right
oh that's fun Mary said do the cards and
the funds could benefit a charity or
something each month oh yeah yeah that's
nice
oh yeah even if it's like like Get Well
cards and then that benefits
like um I mean I've already worked with
the national pediatric Cancer Foundation
so it could benefit them and those are
like Get Well cards or things
oh no
um
yeah that's definitely a fun idea though
but alas my friends another fun idea is
to keep it moving here to our next
contestant
ah
sorry I thought the screen crashed oh my
gosh I thought did y'all hear that
exhale of disappointment
I'm just like oh did everything just
crash but no we're good
all right
so here we go as we say
let's get ready
[Applause]
next up we have the one
the only
Sandy Bernstein my friends
honestly I love people but the older I
get the less time I have for little
white lies and
you all have that colleague who comes to
us again and again with hey did you read
my email
back in the day I'd say oh it must have
gotten caught in my spam filter but now
I'm like absolutely not I know for a
fact I didn't read it because I put it
in my spam folder on purpose thank you
for asking for the 18th time oh and how
about that annoying friend who leaves
you 10 minute voicemails and wants to
know why you haven't responded
the old me would erase their voicemails
and say my phone's been acting weird
the new me doesn't have to lie
I stopped deleting their messages so now
my mailbox is full they can't leave them
anymore problem solved
don't you hate it when someone's running
late and text you I'm almost there
we all know they haven't left the house
now I answer quit lying you're still in
your pajamas and I'm changing into mine
right now
there are still times when I struggle to
be honest like when my husband asked me
how many men I've been with I mean that
really bothers me for two reasons one
it's none of his damn business and two I
honestly don't remember
how many people does the stadium hold
I'm just kidding that's ridiculous it's
a soccer field
and a lot of goals were scored there if
I'm being honest honestly
give it up for Sandy
Give It Up
a lot of goals oh Sandy
my my wife laughed too hard at that that
joke it made me
a bit on uneasy there how hard she
laughed at that one she's like yes queen
go Sandy
hmm
oh yeah Jack said the Stadium's rocking
hilarious
Bobby given the Applause Evelyn liked
the stadium Mary liked it
Lynn said love it Sandy Ed liked the
goals as well
Jones said you described me to
Perfection and the ending joke was great
[Music]
love unlocked lockdown awesome this set
is true big facts
Dan liked it he gave the Applause Jerry
loved the stadium as well
how funny
van giving some Applause here Sandra
thought it was funny as well lots of
goals hilarious
yes these are all jokes though right
yeah these are all jokes you know
very funny Mr eggmail Bob liked the
stadium as well Mary said Strong Finish
Jody said World Cup got nothing on
okay
hilarious
Mike Marr good job coach Tosh loved this
set I was rolling throughout
hilarious
Evelyn said I love that your wife left a
little too hard at that it was a little
unnerving but it's fine
everything's fine
it's all love right
Dino Sandy did you get my email oh my
all right
Evelyn like the old me honest me
structure
Evelyn Thatcher we have two Evelyn's in
here
Evelyn Thatcher said that one
Evelyn medcap was the one that was like
oh I'm so glad your wife laughed at the
the philandering
part
I know I look like a youth pastor that
reformed her
[Music]
very nice
all right
all right well great job there Sandy
great job we have two down two to go my
friend
oh and Jody said Sandy scores more than
soccer players oh
is that true
a hat trick a jimmy hat trick
[Music]
all right anyway
let's keep it moving here we have two
more my friends we have Bob Kirk and
Joan fuchsman so let's not wait anymore
the next one we have
[Applause]
Bob Kirk
up Kirk the theme is honesty I'm all
tapped Out father honestly oh a man
without honor and honesty is a man
without morals
so you were saying judge he should plead
guilty
but he's the lawyer a man without honor
and honesty is a man with no morals
that's that's William Shakespeare no no
it's not I said Dancy Duty right
Integrity is everything well until I get
caught men lie more than women yeah they
lie about their height how much money
they make who says Size Doesn't Matter
it's the thickness of your wallet that
counts no honesty Integrity faithful
trustworthiness sincerity and candor
just like the Seven Dwarfs but there is
no snow white and sadly no happy ending
we don't have a swear jar at our house
no we have a truth jar and it's empty oh
I'm not good at lying I can't lie my
stomach gets all tied up in knots and
nervous oh and Myrtle interrogates me
from the other side of the bathroom door
when I lie I don't get IBS I get lie BS
all she wants is an honest relationship
I had to download the truth Tracker app
on my phone so when I like it if I lie
she gets pinged and I get an electrical
shock employer my nipples hard right now
Pinocchio's got nothing on me you dirty
right
Bob Kurt
yes
the one and only last month's winner by
the way Mr Bob Kirk coming in hot there
with another great set
oh Mary liked the LIE BS
I'll have what he's having said Ed Jack
said brilliant Bob
Evelyn liked the thickness of your
wallet oh so Ellen liked the
philandering joke and the girth joke I
see
I see you Evelyn
oh and both Evelyn's like the thickness
of your wall oh my heavenly day
Jones said oh Joan loved the wallet bit
as well she said so great Jody said Bob
is a certified nut
Sandy truth jar Li BS hilarious Happy
Ending is my favorite said Jack Allen
Dino James Cagney doing Shakespeare
hilarious yeah
Mike Marr like the dirty rat character
I'd like the wallet joke as well love on
lockdown the thickness joke is a good
one Dan said size does matter
Jerry Bob always packs in the jokes in
90 seconds yes
huh
John
good one Bob
oh love the accents as well
Sandra liked it trevarius Young
digging it very nice no Evelyn keep keep
commenting
keep commenting hmm
we appreciate it
Lynn liked the wallet bit as well yeah
it was a good one
my my wife laughed at that one as well
yeah
oh Mary said he's one every time I've
watched well
this is the first time we've had a
four-way
wait a minute I don't want Evelyn to get
any ideas a four-way competition nothing
beyond that nothing premarital here
happening
van given the three thumbs up very nice
OMG
well
you've seen Jack you've seen Sandy
you've seen Bob but we have one more
my friends we have one more so don't
pick yet after this set we are going to
vote
for who wins this month's hundred dollar
joke contest we're gonna bring them on
live on the air
so this is the final contestant
of 2022 this is our final contest of
this year
so ladies and gentlemen prepare
yourselves
as there is only one thing left to do
[Music]
[Applause]
your final finalist
2022 I present to you the one the only
the Joan fuchsman
outside of insurance they say honesty is
the best policy I'm pretty honest
emphasis I'm pretty
I'm honest about the fakeness of my red
hair no point in lying my non-matching
eyebrows are a dead giveaway I couldn't
lie about my weight even if I wanted to
one look at me says I'm not Twiggy or
her twin sister bulimic
what am I less than honest about
my height for one thing I can't bring
myself to say I'm shorter than I was 10
years ago if I keep losing inches and
gaining pounds I'll look like a cheese
wheel only not as tasty
my biggest lie is not really a lie
because I never address it my age
I'm from a long line of women including
my mom who never told anyone their birth
year
dad learned my mom's age 40 years after
their wedding when he accidentally saw
her passport
I'm positive the reason my mother never
got a driver's license was because she'd
have to admit how old she was yeah and
why is age so important does Comcast
really need to know it to give me a
password
they should worry about their customer
service talk about lying but maybe they
should worry about that instead of
wondering if I was born before or after
the Industrial Revolution
I can picture my tombstone
here lies Joan fuchsman birthday and
real hair color unknown
yeah
oh where are we at there it is
woo
amusement
your final finalist
yeah
oh Mary like the cheese well line yeah
that was so funny
very funny
and I'm gonna post the names
in the live chat here one moment my
friends I'm gonna be posting this
foreign
live stream so one moment please
I'll post them in the order so we had
Jack Allen
Sandy Bernstein
Bob cook
oh wait
I'm Joan
fuchsman
kaboom all right the poll is now live my
friend so go vote
remember there's a lot of stake in here
the winner gets a hundred bucks and an
interview on hot breath podcast
we about to go live shouting
oh Bobby said Joan given a lot of
applause
coach Tosh like losing inches in the
cheese wheel
Evelyn liked outside of insurance
Dan said woohoo Evelyn Thatcher the
cheese wheel love Joan disappearing yeah
that was hilarious
Bob Kirk good job Joan eyebrows cheese
wheel the passport yeah
Jack Allen cheese wheel is my favorite
fantastic imagery Mike Mark Goodwin Joan
Mary said I sail Internet and get that
question spot on for senior discount
though
oh Jerry said born before or after the
Industrial Revolution loved the actions
too yeah
Len thanks Joan loved it Ed Rubin great
job Jonah love the lies about age
Dino said I can't lie that was funny oh
I can't lie
I see what you did there
nicely done Dino
Jody said that was funny because we
didn't learn my mom's real birthday
until after she passed oh my gosh
that is hilarious
coach Tosh great job all oh yeah
Sandy said love the bulimic sister of
Twiggy the cheese wheel
Industrial Revolution and Tombstone plus
your hair looks marvelous
[Laughter]
marvelous darling marvelous
I agree
van Kerry said woo-woo
big facts
oh and Evelyn said what a great topic
brought out the best of these fabulous I
can see why it was the four-way final
voting for just one is rough I know I
like literally
my wife and I
debated and then we're like all right
let's sleep on it and then we woke up
and we're like we just can't so
we had we had to do a top four and give
you the problem now now it's your
problem to decide who wins
and Bobby said its official girls are
funny yeah
big facts
big facts indeed
so vote for one and remember as you're
voting you know
remember what you're voting about the
theme was honest
so how did they use that theme
and honestly how funny was it be honest
with yourself now how many laughs are
they getting how just
laugh laugh how funny was it
and uh so far we have 24 votes which is
beautiful so get your votes in we will
do like another minute here what y'all
think another minute here
hey
we could do another minute here
oh Jack Allen said thank you Mary I
massively appreciate that Mary said Jack
I loved yours because duplicate presents
my parents are divorced so that
relates and was true too
yeah that's funny too because my parents
were divorced and I started doing a joke
about
having Four Christmases would like step
parents and stuff so that's um
yeah I'll just steal Jack's joke instead
but just know family do this every
single month
we do this every single month
for anyone who joins our comedy writing
Master Class these are all for graduates
of that online class we have
so if you want to join it is linked in
the comments hotbreathmedia.com
and alas we have arrived
and let's see what we're looking at here
OMG y'all
yo looky here it's looking like
looky there
it's looking like
Sandy Bernstein my friends it's looking
like Sandy Bernstein
is the 2022 November
contest winner but congrats to everyone
you what this is not easy to write a new
set
and then record that set and post that
set it is not easy my friends so do do
do
show them some love
all right and Sandy Bernstein I am
sending you your interview links so
prepare yourself tell your husband he
can go for his walk now
as he normally does when you win he's
like all right I gotta get out of here
here
hilarious
all right Sandy so I just sent you the
interview link
oh and look at all the love coming in
congratulating Sandy oh
good job everyone
oh I love the love y'all I love the love
all right
so let's do this my friends we're about
to bring on our
our winner our final winner
let me just find the
the fancy
fancy fancy winner screen
all right
all right one second let me record the
intro what's goody upper at the verse
welcome back to hot breath this episode
today is with our final 100 joke contest
winner of 2022
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
the one and only
Sandy Bernstein everyone let's give some
love for Sandy Sandy hello hold on there
we go his name yes Bob's name is
the last few months so yeah Bob Bob's
been on a roll but you dethroned him I
I'm amazed I really didn't expect to win
I did I was frantically trying to put on
some makeup
I was not prepared I I didn't even like
update my Facebook page with my latest
shows I
oh take it by surprise but I'm very
happy about it thank you so much and
thank everybody the photo for me it was
very tough competition yeah my my
husband didn't even think I had the best
shot hilarious but he he says he voted
for me though but because he knows you
know she knows how quickly I could get
the locks changed no okay and I live in
the same house
he usually leaves when you win but he's
hanging around for this one no he's
putting on his coat right now
well Sandy congratulations this is so
cool thank you I like I said I'm amazed
I mean all of the entries were really
top-notch yeah and I mean any one of
them
I mean if I if I wasn't you know I
wouldn't even know who to vote for
if it if it wasn't me but the hot
breadth of Earth has spoken they voted
for you what what did you do here the
theme was honest tell us about how you
made this winning set
well I thought about what are like the
little white lies people tell and that's
kind of like where I went with it
because
um you know I looked up like the top
white lies and they were the thing about
you know the email and the text and uh
and voicemail and I thought well that's
all very true
yeah and uh and then I thought about
what kind of Lies do I tell or what I
like to tell yeah I moved into the more
uh personal I guess you could say
oh yeah I don't necessarily say it's
accurate but certainly personal
so you you embellished a little bit
perhaps yeah I'll never tell
well it works
thank you yeah I was uh I was I was
happy about the ending that's probably
my my favorite part of it yeah that one
got a lot of comments during the live
stream people were really Jerry said
stadium is personal
[Laughter]
a good misdirect though you went from
Stadium to like soccer how did how did
you find
how did you realize or like how did you
find that joke
um I don't know I I think maybe I was I
might have been workshopping it with
someone
um with uh with my mentor and he and he
might have uh he might have pitched that
one to me and you know and I wasn't even
sure because I thought well maybe it
should go from Big to bigger but I
wanted to get in the pun about the uh
goal scored so I yeah with soccer I
don't know maybe I don't even know if
the World Cup was going on while I was
writing it but that might have been in
the back of my mind as well
yeah that is that is a good point on
like Mr X though is you can go from like
big to bigger and create like a contrast
that way or big to smaller and credit
contrast that way so you can kind of
flip it either way
yeah and I mean I I mean like the
difference is bothering me because the
difference wasn't necessarily that
glaring but you know I just I just
needed to like I had to get that pun in
at the end of course and you in your
head it wasn't like that much of a
misdirect but then that was the joke
people were saying they loved the most
you know so
that's the thing sometimes you write
something and you're like I don't know
and then you do it on stage and you're
like oh I guess so and then the opposite
can be true too though we're like yeah
this is the one and then the audience is
like nah that ain't it
ain't it yeah that's true I mean I
performed it live a number of times to
crickets
and oh really
yeah that's the only part that even got
a semblance of a laugh was the end
so I just so now that when I do it I
just do the end part I don't even go
through the whole thing necessarily
um that in with my other marriage
material
so you tried this set on stage a few
times oh yes yeah yeah
and uh never got the results that I
wanted to so that's why I was kind of
surprised that that it even made the
finals much less winning
wow
hey you just never know that's why you
always submit you're someone who submits
every single month yeah yeah and I'm
almost glad that you're not doing it
this month because I was thinking to
myself how am I going to find the time
to do this I'm yeah so far so far behind
on so many other things because I was
working on this um you know and I also
like the if then structure because
that's something that I hadn't done
before so I didn't want to like keep
doing the same type of thing so I it
just sort of Lent itself to the then and
now kind of structure I should say oh
shoot wait dive into that a little bit
more what do you mean if then versus
then and now well I mean actually I
meant to say then and now oh okay that's
one of the techniques that you teach in
your effective uh writing with
confidence cool
um
I am a graduate yes you are and that is
one of the the techniques that I really
hadn't used very much but I thought oh
this sounds like a now and then sort of
thing and it really lent itself to that
yeah that's fun yeah I like if then is
one technique but then now and then I
guess I do do that in the class of like
a timeline technique but now and then is
actually a much easier way to like say
that as well uh-huh yeah so you can
bring around that technique there we go
the Sandy Bernstein technique we'll call
it oh no no it's definitely yours but I
use used it so that that was good it's a
I mean I took the class A long time ago
but a lot of it sticks with you
especially if you're trying to practice
it exactly yeah especially if you stick
with it you know like that's that's the
thing is you learn wherever you learn
things it's like they got to put them
into action to really make them your own
yeah yeah and just keep practicing with
it oh and Evelyn said I love your
process oh oh well thank you it's yeah
like I just like I said I had this idea
and I was Googling it and just doing
sort of like a lot of research and
I'm trying to think who said this it
wasn't it was on your podcast but
somebody was saying that when you hit
writer's block one of the things you
could do is research because that's
still writing
um yeah staring at the blank page just
kind of like throw ideas out there and
kind of like try to look into it and
research it
exactly yeah I think a lot of times we
people don't write because they over
complicate that it has to be a certain
thing but at all like each little thing
snowballs and like builds over time
regardless what you're doing yeah
I have to I had I have to like set a
timer I mean that's why the right 10
Club started it's like a 10 minute timer
but I now like I just I'll set like a 20
minute timer and just like all right
whatever I'm just sitting here with this
for the next 20 minutes and whatever
happens with it I just know there's this
one thing I'm focusing on for the next
20 minutes and that's really been
helping me to like get more done in
chunks instead of just over complicating
it
right just saying I can't leave here
until it's finished
I'm gonna give yourself a time limit uh
yeah I mean I just try to get down a
first draft and then I I leave it alone
for a day or two which is why having
more time to do this two weeks as
opposed to a week is is helpful yeah it
gives me more time to let it rest it
gives me more time to sort of maybe you
know run it live or run it past people
and uh so that's good and I I've taken a
lot of the uh contest entries that I've
done and maybe the whole thing doesn't
work on stage but there might be like
one or two jokes that really work and
then sort of lend themselves into other
parts of my set oh that's great like the
um the one that I did a while back about
the um about relationships I don't even
know if it won but it was a fun I know
it was a final but the whole thing about
um you know my marriage is like a fairy
tale uh last night I was sleeping beauty
and he had to find his own happy ending
ah that was the worst yeah that that
still works yeah I don't even think that
that one particular one won it was the
one on relationships so I don't think I
don't think that it won but I know it
was a finalist but Flex yes you're like
I know it was in the finals I know I was
out what the heck
oh but all I could say is that I say
this every time to people is that I
submitted for like almost a year like
eight or nine times before I even made
it into the finals and I just thought
well this is impossible it's never going
to happen but I just I just kept
plugging away yeah and then something
clicked and then you've been in the
finals a lot and won a lot as well
yeah just consistency
yes
oh well I'm so excited for you Sandy
this is this is such a great way to to
end the year of contests here this is so
much fun to do and I love just seeing
people's sex my wife laughing at your
Stadium joke made me very uncomfortable
but um yeah I'm not sure how my husband
feels about it he's you know this is the
first time he saw my set so he kind of
left without comment
that's the funniest but I've I voted for
you hilarious that sounds like something
my wife would say too though so it's all
good yeah
yeah the fact that I could even get him
to stay and watch is is an
accomplishment but it was funny because
it used to be that he would say well you
know you're a funny person but I really
don't think that you're funny on stage
and I was like oh don't hold back tell
me how you really feel yeah right yeah
but then we were at a family function
um we were like with his family and he
said something like oh yeah she's really
good I'm like wait a minute who is this
and he goes well no I I just you're good
but I I don't I won't see you and I
don't like your your comedy because you
always talk about me and I hate it and I
was like
as long as you're not coming to my shows
then we're good yeah it's tough I mean
balancing that balancing like a
relationship and comedy you know it does
require
you got to be very thoughtful about the
time you spend with each because you can
easily let comedy take over your entire
life
oh yes don't I know it and uh
fortunately for me even though he's not
one of these people that's like you know
going to all the shows and you know
being a cheerleader and stuff he is in
his own way and I mean he's supportive
in that he never says oh you're going
out again tonight yes uh you know he's
always like how'd you do did you make
him laugh and and uh and it's a good
thing because he's kind of a homebody so
it works out he's he's happy to stay at
home while I'm out running around and
he'd rather I not be like bugging him to
go out so it kind of works out so yeah
that's same same with my relationship
you know like I think it's supportive
spouse or whatnot doesn't they don't
have to support by going to shows but
just understanding and not like stifling
or questioning can just give us the
freedom to go and do what we need to do
yeah and I mean it also sort of you know
you have to
um you know build a thick skin and a lot
of self-reliance and you can't like
totally depend on your partner to give
you validation I mean that's a lot of
them and it's asking a lot of them to
make them sit through a show where
you're bombing because that's
uncomfortable for them I mean I kind of
you know I'm so focused on how
uncomfortable it is for me but then I
think well what if there's somebody that
you really love and you see them like
floundering and failing and you know
after sitting through eight Comics doing
the same bombing you know like and then
it's your turn and they're like uh
yeah we we also need to be empathetic to
our spouses as well of like what we're
doing isn't normal and it can be hard
for people to understand like with a
like a normal human mindset of like wait
you just want to go out and talk to
strangers in a bar every night you know
so we need to be empathetic to like also
what we're
the lifestyle that we're pursuing is
also not normal so that them being maybe
if they don't understand it them being
still supportive in their way really
goes a long way so it's kind of it's it
goes both ways
yeah yeah I mean like last Sunday it was
kind of like rainy here and there was
like a narrow window where it wasn't
raining where he could go walking so I
was in the middle of right 10 he goes
well I'm going now I was like oh okay
and I was like oh I'm sorry I didn't get
to walk with you today because well we
know what your priority is and that's
comedy and I was like well you know
and he's like yeah I know it's true I
said well hey you know you're right I
love that oh my wife just say well
you're right yep
that's a very useful skill as a wife
ladies listen closely to say you're
right is to acknowledge that your
husband is right
I mean it does happen now and then and
when it does you have to acknowledge it
wow
okay okay
what does we don't want to admit to it
as it happens and we appreciate it we
appreci men are very sensitive we're you
know we're we're actually very sensitive
we need those words of affirmation no
matter how tough we try to act yes I I
got a text last night while I was at the
show with uh with Bobby and Joyce and
it's from my husband and he's like I
mopped the floor don't come home and
mess it up
[Music]
you too
but that was great because I won't mop
the floor so I mean you know that's
better than buying me roses facts
because I'm not gonna yeah
like blur my background because my house
looks like an episode of cops
my like questionable looking like salt
shaker and I meant to hide that I get so
many rude comments oh is that what that
is in the background I'll shake I gotta
get that it's very distracting hilarious
[Laughter]
my toys to myself like going one of your
Stadium toys there I don't know anyway
but where what um is there anything
you'd like to promote or anything else
you'd like the world to know before we
land the plane
oh yeah I've got a ton of stuff but like
I never I haven't updated my Facebook
page so I'll have to do that today so
you can include it in the notes but yeah
yeah I have a lot of different shows
coming up uh starting with the ones that
I produce uh I do the show that you did
that you um got a standing ovation
ah
thank you thank you yes God try it out
comedy which is uh usually the first
Monday of the month in Columbia Maryland
and at Busboys and Poets and we are
having a show tomorrow which is another
thing I have to do is is you know talk
contact all the comedians with the
timing sheet and stuff yeah you got all
that uh so much yeah so much detail but
um and it's funny because I spent all
this time on the timing sheet like down
to the minute because my executive
producer and founder Rich madsel he's
really into like you know planning and
um so I took a lot of these things uh
from him that I do so I spent all this
time on this Excel spreadsheet at times
The Showdown of the minute and I can
count on one hand the number of times
that that has
stayed accurate because minute people
always like drop out or they're late and
I have to switch the order and I always
include on the note to comedians you
know please be here before the show
starts because otherwise this timing
sheet is out the window and
every you know and especially with coven
and everything anybody who's running a
temperature not feeling well of course
should not come so I've had people for
that reason
um and so there's always different
things but you know you go in with your
best intentions and you hope that what
you have spent time putting together is
actually going to translate into reality
but we run a tight ship we always start
on time and end on time and uh so that's
awesome yeah that's always the first
Monday so it's this Monday if anybody's
in Columbia we still we normally sell
out the show and we probably will but
there's still still a few tickets left
if anybody is in the Baltimore
Washington area and wants to come to
that just go to tryitoutcomedy.com
and uh it's also on my I did post about
the show last night so that's also on my
Facebook page the next one of that is
actually going to be on a Tuesday
because Monday January 2nd is a holiday
so it's going to be on Tuesday January
3rd and so of those tickets are going to
go on sale probably tomorrow night and
then I'll start posting that flyer and
you know really good lineups as you know
because we get people of your caliber
great yeah I was just pulling up the
website here I'm gonna definitely put
that in the show notes yeah and then um
the show that I I produce a couple of
monthly open mics with another comedian
uh Walter Gottlieb and we do one of the
second Monday of the month uh in
Columbia at another place called Home
Slice Pizza
and the name of the mic is called the
slice is right
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so I'll be posting on my page
uh that for trying to get comedians to
sign up and uh and Rich my executive
producer comes to that so I tell people
well if you want to do like your set of
Clean Comedy because the tried out
comedy show is a clean comedy show you
know just come in with five minutes of
clean material it can be like an
audition because Rich normally comes to
all these things but otherwise they're
no content restrictions but we've
actually discovered like a few kind of
newer people because he his thing is he
wants to put on at least one newbie on
every show and we don't always get to do
that but you know we've discovered
people like that and actually that's how
we got Gary Bachmann was on the show hot
breath in a few months ago so that's how
that's how he got on the show because uh
you know Rich yeah I mean you know we
appreciate people's work ethic and when
we see people putting in the work even
if they're newer you know we want to
give them an opportunity exactly yeah so
that's good so we book months in advance
but um you can always anybody who's
interested can always hit me up and I'll
probably say yeah send me five or ten
minutes of you doing clean comedy
because they're very strict guidelines
you know like no obviously no f-bombs
but it's an older crowd and they don't
like like drug humor they don't even
like weed jokes and uh it's weird
because they don't like people yelling
although one of our favorite Headliners
that's all she does and they love her so
go figure they don't they don't like
people to sing to them but you know some
of our most popular people do sing to
them so it's it's a very it's a You Know
Rich has a very good understanding of
the audience because they're basically
his peeps
and uh so he's I I when I haven't
listened to him I've normally been wrong
so that's another case where I can say
yeah you were right but he gives me a
lot of latitude but I I found that his
judgment is is 99 correct
um but the open mics that we do they're
no content restrictions uh the other one
that we do is called evil Bad Kitty and
that's named after Walter's cat wow and
that's always the third Friday of the
month uh and another piece of pizza
place in Rockville Maryland uh called
Sam's Pizza and uh so that's fun
sometimes uh if you go to Sam's pizzas
Instagram page the owner will live
stream it
really see it not always but sometimes
and I have to warn people like oh you're
being live streamed most people are like
oh yeah yeah but I have to remember that
not everybody wants to be live streamed
yeah so we try to warn people about that
uh then as far as my shows uh this let's
see there's a really cool comedy club
that just opened in Baltimore called the
port and a gentleman named Matt Hurley
runs it he just opened it a month ago
and it seats 70 people and it is an
awesome venue and so you've got to
interview him for hot breath because
he's very much got that DIY
um you know attitude so uh and I told
him about you so we're he's gonna be you
know
eventually and maybe I can combine it
with bringing you back to to uh
to the bus boys and Poets because uh I
try not to repeat any Headliners for at
least a year so of course yeah yeah for
sure might be a little while but he's
but he's great we're doing a show there
um and I just suggested it to a man
another comedian Adam friesman we saw
that there wasn't anything on a schedule
for Christmas Eve which is Saturday
December 24th and so we're doing a show
of Jewish comedians hilarious oh I love
that yeah and uh and you know Walter's
also going to be on that show so we we
haven't like really started promoting it
yet but it will be there if you're in
the Baltimore area in Fells Point
looking for something to do on Christmas
Eve you don't have to be Jewish you just
have to want to laugh and uh yeah he's
had sold out shows he had Liz Mill there
last night sold out all the shows I have
you ever interviewed her oh yeah yeah I
had her on when she was in Atlanta yep
so she's on right yes yeah yeah so her
Show's all sold out and uh yeah I just
pulled up their website yeah yeah they
have a lot of great Comics coming
through yeah and I've done like Tuesday
night shows
um there on the you know sort of on the
Fly uh and I've gotten it's wonderful
audiences I mean even on a Tuesday night
they're they've always got at least a
dozen people or more in there and they
come to laugh and it's just a wonderful
place and a huge addition to the
Baltimore Comedy scene so I can't say
enough nice things about it you know I I
brought uh Bobby and uh Joyce there to
take a look at it and you know often
they fell in love with it they're like
we gotta come back here and put this on
the tour I said you know and and that
was like oh sure that's awesome yeah so
that's a great place uh I'm there I'm
there it seems like a lot of Tuesday
nights but I never know till the last
minute uh and then this Friday on the
9th I have a show in Leesburg Virginia
and
um uh like it it said um Mexican
restaurant I think it is so I'm blanking
out on the name but I'll I'll post that
on Facebook page yeah yeah I need to
repost it it's it's there in the feed
but it's buried and then on the and then
like on Saturday the uh I believe it's
the 17th I'm doing a show in Baltimore
at Goldie Seafood carryout and I have to
drop
yeah I don't I don't think I have that
on the page yet and uh and then I know
there's other stuff too but I I could go
on and on I just need to like get it
together and start posting these things
so you can easily pull it up for the
show I hear grinding I love it yeah no
it's it's crazy last night yesterday I
did like um a bridal shower for a
colleague and
um yes I I didn't get paid but I got fed
but she said she wants to get me
something but you know I had my business
card so she's putting a business card
into every goodie bag so yeah that's
great that's how you get referrals and
people see you in a private event and
they're like oh yeah I could have comedy
at my event and then and then I went
straight down to Fells Point and and met
um you know Joyce and Bobby we had a
great time and they're two hilarious
women and the crowd and they also
brought another person uh Thai funny and
he was hilarious you know there are from
Alabama so and they they really enjoyed
themselves at Max's Tap House and like
uh Matt Hurley who has the port he
started out with Bill Franks and now you
know Bill Franks is running it and um
yeah and it's like I said it's another
good venue on a Saturday night an open
mic that you don't have to sell your
soul to get on stage time I that's why
I'm right I'm like halfway between
Baltimore and DC but I seem to do a lot
more in Baltimore because the scene is a
lot less clicky it's a lot more open and
inclusive I mean I do stuff in DC and
Northern Virginia
um but that's part of the reason why
Walter and I are running the mics
because first of all there's not a lot
in like Montgomery and Howard County in
Maryland and also you know we welcome
Comedians and it's a very open
supportive atmosphere that it's one of
those open mics where the comedians
actually stay for the whole thing oh wow
yes and their noses are not in their
notebooks uh it's like a really positive
vibe so even though we don't have that
many civilians attending and it's all
comedians it's not like death like your
typical open mic with all comedians yeah
still productive you still get good
feedback yes yes definitely so I'll I'll
be posting the links to that on my page
and and the Flyers to that so if
anybody's in the area or traveling
through uh Baltimore or DC you know we
you know we love people we welcome new
people and uh and it's a very good
positive experience oh my gosh you just
made my heart smile I love I love
hearing that
oh God out here getting it Sandy
congratulations I love your hustle and
it really shows with you winning all
so many of these contests but then also
just the shows and everything you're
doing with that positive intent I just
love it thank you so much for yeah
writing that through comedy I'm telling
you it's a none of this would have been
possible without hot breath I have to I
have to give it this A you know genuine
honest plug because during the pandemic
um Angela Moore was the one who happened
to post in East Coast Comedians and so I
started tuning in and it really taught
me how to write a joke I I really didn't
know how to write a joke I mean if I
look back on some of my early uh
postings and I'm like oh that's not even
a joke and uh and I brought Joan into
the fold and uh you know and I remember
the first few months he's like this
nobody voted for you this is terrible
now
just keep doing and now she's winning
like every day I'm like geez did I do
the right thing now I'm not winning
because Jonas
but yeah so it's just it's just wraps as
you say and the whole uh DIY sort of
work ethic that you promote through hot
breath because you know I get up all in
my feelings like oh nobody's me
and I'm not on the cool shows and you
know I just in my in my mind I hear your
voice saying don't focus on what you
can't control just make your own
opportunities and that has really served
me well and I try to you know spread
that ethos and I you know when I see
other comedians doing the same thing
like Matt starting this Comedy Club I
mean renting a place in Fells Point is
not cheap
um he's like a a biochemist you know
with a PhD but he just he quit that and
is doing this full time whoa yes and I
mean this place doesn't even yet have a
liquor license or sell food it's all
BYOB and bring in your own food so I I
mean you know this it just blows me away
that what he's been able to do and and
just that huge leap of faith and he was
originally only going to have it shows
you know Thursday through Saturday but
it just took off and now like Sunday is
his day off but half the time people are
you know running producing shows there
on Sunday and so
all the time and uh so yeah definitely
definitely someone you should interview
for the podcast sure wow that sounds
amazing yeah yeah and I mean he hasn't
even hadn't even really been in the
comedy scene that long but you know he
just saw a need for it he saw the as
Jeff Foxworthy would say he saw the
empty parkings place yes yes
and Fell's point is like they like like
the main entertainment sort of District
in Baltimore and there's a ton of foot
traffic so there's you know people just
walk by like oh comedy show
and uh and it's wonderful plus you know
the crowds are not super drunk because
they're they're not you know they're not
selling alcohol so the crowds are great
hey man they're incredible I mean it's
just like comedy magic here yeah well
yeah I would definitely love to get up
there and definitely love to have Matt
on the show for sure
ah
well should we land This Plane I think I
just heard something crash out there oh
yeah you know Mike has a cat hasn't been
fed so I'm surprised that you're not
seeing her butt Star right now she's
kind of like circling like a vulture
down here but she's being camera shy
yeah today is we're uh doing decorating
today my wife we pulled everything out
of the attic it's funny anytime we go
visit
uh you know my in-laws new things come
back and then this is the first year
I've seen the accumulation of Christmas
decorations like we had a little bit and
then now it was like tub after tub and I
was like oh so this is how that works
it's just one little bit at a time and
then all of a sudden it's everywhere
yeah I mean I'm so since I've been doing
comedy of course it's taken over my life
a lot of times I don't get the stupid
tree up until
um until Christmas Eve oh you see like
Tom puts together the tree but I
decorate it and um yeah I just remember
last year like
um you know doing a zoom meeting with my
camera off and hanging Christmas
ornament
no yeah no and uh you know and I do a
certain amount of baking I haven't even
started on anything yeah there's still
time we're over Achievers here yeah yeah
so the when you said that you weren't
doing a contest in December I was like
relieved because I was like okay now now
I have to get busy with this but then I
have all these like different things on
my to-do lists that are all comedy and
no Christmas and I'm like
yeah somehow I'll get it done I where I
where I work is we get a lot of time off
and we get three floating holidays so I
gotta put in for this Friday and of
course you know I'll be leaving early to
go to Leesburg Virginia so I don't know
how much Christmas stuff I'll get done
but yeah it's all good it's a yeah yeah
it'll get it'll get done one way or the
other
congratulations man oh man what a great
way to end this year of contests great
job congrats yeah and congratulations to
all the finalists I mean I I honestly if
I I couldn't even choose the best one uh
then we're all great there so I can see
why you and your wife ended up you know
settling on four because I don't know
how you could possibly eliminate any of
those four yeah yeah so well deserved
though you you won you won by a fair
margin so it was the To the victor goes
the spoils so congrats on another win
thank you and like I said I'm like I'm
just shocked and well happy but I did it
yeah
it just goes to say I mean there's some
months where it's like this is a winner
and it's not even in the finals and
other times I'm like nah you know I I
entered and then all of a sudden uh oh
I'm in the finals you just never know
that's why you always got to throw it up
throw those shots that's right so
anybody who thinks that oh this sucks
I'm not gonna enter it just enter it
you know what what do you have to lose
you never know and my message to Bobby
you got you gotta start getting in this
contest girlfriend
you know a challenge I'm issuing down
Bobby Sutton
the call out okay Bobby shutting her out
yeah okay yeah if you want to go in this
hot flash tour
we'll try to hold her accountable for
January for sure that's right I'm
holding her feet to the fire well
congrats Sandy and uh you have a great
Sunday out there and uh well-deserved
win is again
well thank you very much
um yeah this has made my my day my week
my month so this is awesome good thank
you thank you everyone who who voted and
had kind words to say
um as Joel would say I love you all oh
oh and I love you all as well
you have a good day out there Sandy
thank you you too Joel bye
all right
[Music]
congratulations to Sandy thank you
everyone
for hanging out on this live stream I
love you all so much thank you for
spending your valuable time with us on a
Sunday
so thank you all so much this was the
final contest of this year but if you
want to compete in future ones just go
join our comedy writing Master Class
Linked In the show notes and go connect
with Sandy congratulate her and maybe
get some tips on how to run shows in
your own scene
but uh that is it until next Monday
right here on
hot bread
no
go forth with your Sundays my friends
y'all are awesome thank you so much for
spending your valuable time with us I
really appreciate it
but um that's it
that is it oh my gosh this is it
y'all have a happy holiday season out
there
and um
we'll see you on the other side huh
all right we'll buy y'all
bye
foreign